ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre si j'en juge par
vos déclarations vous souhaitez faire de
la reconquête industrielle votre
priorité vous avez récemment déclaré
dans le journal les échos que vous vous
battrez pour chaque emploi industriel
menacé
quelle belle déclaration en sarthe vous
voilà confrontés à des travaux pratiques
c'est le moment de passer des intentions
aux actes dans quelques jours le
couperet définitive du tribunal de
commerce de nanterre devrait tomber ce
sont près de 900 emplois industriels des
sites arjowiggins de
saint-mars-la-brière et bessé sur braye
en sarthe qui pourrait être rayé d'un
trait de plume mais aussi autant
d'emplois de sous traitants ce drame
économique est un drame humain pour
plusieurs centaines de familles de
salariés celle de l' usine de bessé sur
braye notamment territoire à la limite
de la sarthe et du loir-et-cher vivent
dans un secteur extrêmement défavorisés
sur le plan industriel que leur restera
t-il l'état ne peut pas abandonner les
salariés d'arjowiggins à leur sort ne
serait ce que par ça parce que sa
responsabilité est dans ce dossier toute
particulière en effet l'état au travers
de la bpi a été associés à la
gouvernance de l'entreprise comme
actionnaire principal de sa maison mère
sequana au vu de la situation actuelle
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il a singulièrement manqué de
clairvoyance
à situation exceptionnelle nous
attendons monsieur le ministre un
traitement exceptionnel
la présidente de la région des pays de
la loire christelle morançais prête à
engager sa collectivité pour contribuer
au sauvetage de cette industrie et des
emplois qui y sont attachés quelles
initiatives comptez-vous mettre en
oeuvre de manière urgente pour
accompagner la région et pour que votre
priorité affichée de sauver les emplois
industriels soit dans la sarthe une
réalité comment entendez vous prendre en
compte le caractère exceptionnel du
dossier arjowiggins
pour vous répondre la parole et ses
couacs arrêté en juillet auprès du
ministre économie et des finances afin
de ne pas nuire une hache et la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vogel vous m'interrogez sur la
situation des sites d'arjowiggins de
sites en sarthe un site dans l'aisne je
veux rappeler ici que l'état a travaillé
toute l'année 2018 et une reprise
globale de ces trois sites qui n'a
malheureusement pas vu le jour suite à
un contentieux prononcée par une cour
britannique qui faisait peser un
contentieux de 100 millions d'euros sur
le repreneur s'il reprenait dans les
circonstances le site
nous avons donc repris le dossier début
janvier suite à la au placement en
redressement judiciaire des trois sites
c'est grâce à l'état que la
l'exploitation a pu se poursuivre c'est
grâce également à l'état que plusieurs
repreneurs ont présenté un dossier sur
le site de château thierry sur le site
de loups bourré et vous le savez un
repreneur avait présenté un dossier sur
les trois sites
mercredi dernier ce repreneur a indiqué
qu'il n'était pas en mesure de
rassembler l'ensemble de l'argent pour
le mois d'avril pour la reprise des
trois sites
nous avons donc recommencer le travail
jeudi vendredi samedi dimanche lundi
mardi pour trouver une solution
main dans la main avec madame laurence
et puisque vous l'avez bien dit l'argent
public est aujourd'hui réunies pour
faire face à cette reprise
nous sommes aux côtés des salariés aux
côtés des organisations syndicales pour
trouver une solution
il reste 20 millions d'argent à trouver
20 millions d'argent privé et là c'est
beaucoup plus difficile et cet argent ne
pourra pas faire l'objet d'une garantie
de l'état ce sont les règles du jeu je
veux dire ici que l'état n'a pas à
rougir du travail qu'il fait sur les
dossiers de reprise de sociétés en
difficulté dans trois cas sur quatre
nous trouvons une solution et j'aurais
été ravi que vos matériaux juillet sur
la situation d'arc par exemple 5000
emplois dans les hauts de france pour
lequel nous venons de trouver une
solution
aujourd'hui c'est un fait l'industrie
créé plus d'emplois qu'elle n'en détruit